情報に誤りがあると申し訳ないので一応
スマホに情報をまとめさせていただいたの
でそれで間違いないようにちょっと見
ながら話させていただきますとりあえず8
動画のタイトルにある通り私はじめシャツ
を
お仕事の都合増 pcr 系さを受ける
タイミングがあって同検査を受けた結果8
これないです妖精ということで
完全しております
今そういう状況ですね現状についてお話し
させていただきますえっとただいまですね
その保健所から連絡取り合って自宅療養し
ておりますここ今東京のおうちで誰もい
ないんですけどもここでしばらく隔離生活
というかしばらく大知事が出ない自宅療養
とさせて頂いきます幸い今のところ症状は
出ておりません元気なんですよこれ長くて
3回打ったのもかなり大きかったせいか
保護想像がなくて熱もないして体のだるさ
嗅覚味覚もまったく問題なすちょっと喉が
ガラガラするなぐらいですねそれ本当に何
も肖像なくてなんだか元気ぐらいなんです
けどもなんだの今のところ体調の心配は台
丈夫なんですけども
どちらかというと今日そして明日
そしてここが1週間くらいずっとかなり
仕事が佐狡詰まってましてかなりたくさん
の方にご迷惑をおかけしているという現状
がすごく
悔しいというか悲しいなって言う
新疆で結構最悪ですでこれらの症状なん
ですけれどもこればかりは個人の個人で
かなり差がある事なのでが一概に皆さんも
これ何がたら僕みたいに大丈夫というわけ
ではないっていうことはあの頭に入れて
おいて下さい物ロンボクワクチン接種した
んで1か月前には口3回目接種してるんで
それのおかげで症状がかなり緩和されて
いるっていう部分もあると思うんで
backs 打てなかったらどうなってる
かもわからないし中にはワクチン打って
なくても無症状の人もいらっしゃるって
いうお話も聞いたことがあるのでこんなに
個人差があるんですよこれナビですの少女
って僕は大丈夫でも僕が誰かに移してその
人が重症化する可能性があるので若くても
元気な人でも僕みたいに6少女が限らない
よっていうのはちょっとこのどうぞって
伝えたてくださいや草付き5なったこと誰
から打ったのかとか全く身に覚えがなくて
相当気をつけてはいたんですよお仕事
じゃあマスクを果たさなきゃいけないとき
以外は確実にマスクつけてましたし会食と
かも絶対言ってないし飲みの場とかも入っ
ていません何か仕事が結構最近たくさん
あったからちょっとあー with は
絶対教をつけようと思って生活して何で
かなり気をつけてはいたと思うんですけど
それで正直かかると思ってなかったですし
たい子もかなりお仕事そしてスケジュール
があったと思うんですけれども関係者の皆
さまに大変なご迷惑をおかけしております
本当に申し訳ございません
めっちゃ悔しというかもうどうすれば
よかったんやもう1句チェーンもちゃんと
売ったろにゃう
だるいな
て掃除機を持っています本当にもう先の
下宿機能を東京の感染者数4000人以上
が出ているので正直僕だけじゃなくもう誰
か立ってもおかしくない状況ではあると
思いますのであの本当にお仕事に影響が出
てしまったほとんどが本当に僕は今とても
来やすいですいやマジで
全部の井戸タクシー度なんですよいまて外
出るとき絶対マスクつけてるし人と会う
回数も全力で避けてるしもうごめんなさい
は来てもさんが言ってるし正直どうすれば
かかんなかったのが俺は分からないです
そして最近の話ですと畑肇社長の畑の
イベントがあったんですけれども当時造形
さしたんですけどと自体んせんでし
イベントにご来場頂いた皆様にも大変ご
心配をおかけして申し訳ございません一度
イベント中もお客さんと近づくときは必ず
セパレーターというか仕切りを挟んに接し
ていたので十分な感染予防対策をとった
うえで開催させて頂いたので来場いただい
た皆様が濃厚接触に当たるということは
ございませんと言っても間違いなく心配さ
れていると思いますので本当に5先輩を
おかけして申し訳ございません今のところ
はですけど僕は重症化させないことも
すごいホッとしてるんですけれども本当に
いろんな各所をかけにご迷惑おかけしてい
て本当に申し訳ございません
んーでもこれどうってではよかったんだよ
ここにさんにずれ盛大に飲み会行ったりと
かながら大人数で返したくとか言ってたら
本当に俺が悪かったなってなるんですけど
もまでと自信持って言えるくらいかなり気
をつけて生活はしていたので
なんかもう悔しいです本当に year
そう
こんな土木肖像がどう変わるかわかんない
のでしばらくは東京のを打つで一人で
自宅療養させていただきます差分なんです
けどは口に3回打っといてよかったです
いや無症状ながら逆に怖いんですよ自覚が
なかったからいやー
すいませんちょっと結構を突っ込んでます
なんか仕事がないこの先支部とかない1
週間とかだったら百歩譲って良かったん
ですけどこの先かなり仕事が好きずる
詰まってたんで本当にそれがもう
色んな人に迷惑かけてて辛いほど辛いの
一言に尽きますつまりかなり市場の話が出
てしまってるんですけども無症状で映るの
で本当にイマイチの皆さんこれの対策をし
て生活して頂けると本当に嬉しいです5
言われているのは1週間ぐらいですね1
週間ほどは8自宅隔離ということでお家で
ちょっと症状を見ながら療養させて
いただきます皆さんもどう元気を付けて
下さい